good news baseball fans scott garcia ben
mcdonald back with you from camden yards
where the tarp is off and we are just
about ready to play baseball tonight
orioles and red sox first to four and
that's the man who gets the ball tonight
ben orioles are playing well red sox are
playing well and matt harvey's on the
mound and and pitching as good as he has
in a long time and he'll try to get four
wins in a row since the first time back
in 2015 was the last time he did it with
the mets and he got him
so a nice start for matt harvey take
their swings off the left-hander eduardo
rodriguez
he's done in the year he's 4-0 with a
4.1 era didn't play in 2020 had
complications
due to kovid but he has bounced back
with a strong year you talk about a
strong year his best year was 2019 he
won 19 ball games with a 3-8 era
2-1
fly ball center field for dugo coming
hard won't get there falls in mullen's
reddit perfectly and stands at second
base and that one stroked on a line
caught by renfro he'll fire back in
and look at this mullins is going to be
doubled up
mullins doubled up a base running
mistake
and a big big play for the red sox here
right away a gift falling in their laps
oh that's a huge mistake by mullins you
know nobody out in the inning and he's
thinking this ball is going to be i
don't know what he was thinking over the
head of renfro and right field i mean
the ball was spanked in that direction
no question about it but he's going to
be back tied up there's nobody out
[Music]
pay off pitch try to fight that one off
and he does down the line
didn't kill it but he's heading to
second and he's going to get there
standing up
how about that for a double uh swing one
way and the ball goes the other
2-2 pitch
bounce to the left side galves up with
it to malayka and that'll end the red
sox second inning
red sox down orioles coming to bat
bronco lead it off no score
loops one into center field verdugo
won't get that
one it's a face hit and ryan mount
castle
reaches base for the 14th consecutive
game
2-2
got him he struck him out
and that will retire the side one man
left
and a bounty ball the first baseman flip
on to the bank oh it's off of harvey
debra's off to the races he's heading
for second
and he'll get there that was a terrible
feed by valencia the first baseman i
mean that should have been an easy out
with a little underhand flip
and here's vazquez with a man in scoring
position
runner going to third and the throw is
going to be late he held on to the bag
rafael devers with a depth of third
against severino and harvey devers at
third with two down here's hunter renfro
there's a line driving a base hit
that'll chase in a run
and to score rafael devers so they make
the error hurt
hunter renfro picks up his 15th rbi and
the red sox lead at one-nothing and
that'll bring up dolbeck with two one
and two out
oh two
swinging a high fly ball that's driven
deep that's way back there and kiss that
one goodbye
home run for bobby dalbeck
as he spanks a three run shot and the
red sox lead it four to nothing a
hanging slider and dalbeck crushed it
top of the lineup cedric mullins first
pitch swinging fly ball deep right
center way back
and it hops into the stands for a ground
rule double
[Applause]
mullins on second with the automatic
double
[Applause]
well cedric mullins continues to wear
out left-handed pitching and the reason
is he really hangs in there there's no
movement away from the plate and the
orioles have two on i said bat by austin
hayes one strike pitched my drive base
hit center field mullins around third he
gets the green light the throw comes
into third and trey mancini has an rbi
and the orioles are on the board
[Applause]
orioles and the lead off
batter on in the first inning and in the
third inning and mount castle trying to
get on board here in the sixth
3-2
mount castle drives this one deep right
center field this one is headed for the
bleachers and it's gone
it lands just short of them as it goes
over the wall ryan melt castle his
second home run and the orioles inch a
bit closer it's 4-2 boston in the sixth
and a base hit
he didn't think as hot as he has been he
would go the night without a head and he
reaches to begin the eighth inning
christian vasquez over three
two down a man aboard two down and the
red sox eighth inning
and that one stroked into left down the
line and that ball is going to drop in
and roll to the base of the fence here
comes devers he's rounding trying to
score the throw home and he's safe
and the red sox grab
an additional run it is five to two
fine drive past bogarts into left field
ryan mautcastle with his third hit of
the game
[Applause]
falling two strikes to galvez
lined up the middle base head
mount castle will hold at second as
verdugo
picks it up
and the orioles get the tying run to the
plate
dylan tate is out and isaac matson
making his big league debut there's
marwin
one out one on
and he's going to rope this one hit it
deep into the corner that ball slamming
off the board
dalbeck heading hard into third they're
gonna send him home
and he is gonna slide in safely red sox
add on now six to two here in the ninth
inning two strike pitch hit in the air
left field deep hayes back on the track
jumps up and hayes took it back
as austin hayes backed up jumped up at
the wall said austin hayes yeah he took
a home run away
phillips valdez 9 games he's been in 1-0
record
solid e.r.a 11 in the third innings
pitch 10 strikeouts five walks a 2-1
strikeout to walk ratio
and a 2-2
from the righty
in there for strike three
one man out
red sox ahead six to two ninth inning
with two away
and a swing and a miss to put it into it
red sox win it 6-2 the final they take
game one here in baltimore but they've
won every time they played this season
and the red sox improved to 20 and 13.
that's the best record in major league
baseball
final score red sox six and the orioles
two